-Thanks to newly developed
technology,
we here at "Late Night"
now have the ability
to record the tiny voice that is
inside Donald Trump's head.
And you might be surprised
to know that,
like everyone's inner voice,
Donald Trump's is filled with
paralyzing fear and self-doubt.
It's easily distracted.
So here is the tiny voice in
the back of Donald Trump's head.
♪♪♪♪
[ Applause ]
-I just want to thank...
-Hey, Donald.
It's the tiny voice
in the back of your head.
And it's time for you
to face facts.
You are way more comfortable
standing with children
than you are
when you stand with adults.
[ Laughter ]
Because with children,
you fit right in.
You can have your hands at your
side and swing back and forth
and get easily distracted
and no one even notices.
Plus you're so much stronger
than them.
You could pick up
this kid next to you
and just toss him into the lawn.
Stop his dumb smile there.
Yeah.
I hope you're ready
to get tossed.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, who's that hot lady
over there?
I wonder if she's single.
Oh, oh, I recognize her.
Oh, you did it again.
You are going straight to hell.